foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what's up
foreign
[Music]
how is everybody doing tonight
doing well the few the proud braving the
the rain what is that what is rain what
is rain yes we need it my name is Karen
I'd say no to the hail I like I like
your spirit
um my name is Karen and I am very very
happy you are with us tonight here in
this room as well as online glad you
were here uh it takes courage to walk in
the doors of a church
whether you've been here a lot or you've
been here a little
um
sometimes it takes courage to walk in
the doors of the church so I just want
you to know that you are welcome here to
be your full and wonderful self I just
have a couple of announcements
uh ways to get connected here one is for
tonight and one is for about three weeks
from tonight uh I bet the kids know what
night tonight is
yes it is hat Creek night
it is the first Sunday of the month and
at the table every first Sunday of the
month after the service we go hang out
at hat Creek Burger Company uh right on
the corner of Woodbridge and 78
uh to eat together and hang out together
and just continue the conversations that
we have in here so we would love to have
you there again that's tonight
immediately after the service hat Creek
Burger Company the second announcement
is our state of the table meeting that
happens twice a year and we are having
that meeting in three weeks September
24th 24th so 24th that will also be
immediately after the service that
Sunday evening what is the state of the
table you may ask well it's kind of like
the State of the Union Address only much
smaller
but it's where we talk about uh how
things are going here at the table our
goals
we revisit our mission our vision our
values we talk about any leadership
transitions things that you need to stay
in the know here so if you have any sort
of vested interest in the table that is
something that you'll want to attend
again that September 24th Sunday
immediately after the service if you
have any questions about that feel free
to ask me or Brett will be happy to tell
you more about it so
um
how about if we transition into worship
I know Mindy has a great set planned for
us and let's just allow ourselves to be
present for it
to be here it is such a beautiful
communal expression to be able to
worship together and I've been off for
the last month I wasn't around in July
and so this is one of the things that I
missed is communal worship being able to
come together and sing together and be
with God together so will you pray with
me
God thank you for tonight thank you for
these people here and joining us online
God help us to remember that we are
connected always
with each other and with you
so help us to bring our full selves here
remembering that we are loved and
accepted by you God
and help this to be a place where that
is expressed fully too that everyone
here feels fully loved and accepted
so God we open our hearts and our minds
to you
we set aside
just the busyness
things on the horizon or things past
just to be here now
thank you God in Jesus name amen
thanks Karen it's so good to have you
Gary back in the room your presence is
felt when you're here and it's missed
when it's not here so
um will you guys go ahead and stand with
us we actually
um we have several people in our in our
band who are out of town this weekend
with Memorial Day and then Caleb Rob who
was going to be singing tonight ended up
with a sore throat and couldn't join us
so this is a commission to all of you
who can sing in the mail register to
please sing out because what you have
here is Sisterhood of the Traveling
musicians and we're gonna do our best we
had actually picked several songs that
were like guy girl duet echoey Parts as
you would have it you know it's just
gonna be us holding down the mail part
so please join us join in yes
um but I will say when we first entered
this room tonight we just were kind of
warming up warming up and getting our
sound levels set and thank you to our
amazing sound team in the back who has
done so much
to be here for us and they let us just
go off on this little
creative Venture we ended up just in in
a little pocket of worship where we were
just singing all these different songs
that were coming to mind on our heart
and it was it was this beautiful moment
that just reminded me why Times Like
These are so valuable
um because we all have these shared
experiences as we go throughout our week
of the highs and the lows the stressors
the the busyness all of the stuff
um and in that moment it was just us it
was just the music it was just our
voices it was just connection with god
with each other and so I say all that to
say enter into that moment with us
tonight where it's just gonna be us in
this room it's going to be our voices
and the instruments and connecting with
God and with one another so you're
invited into that with us and uh like I
said sing out on those
[Music]
foreign
I will walk in the land of the living my
soul from Death my feet from stumbling I
will walk in the land of the living
[Music]
thank you
and I love you Lord
for you have delivered me
and I love you Lord for you have
delivered my soul from Death my feet
from stumbling I will walk in the land
of the living my soul from Death my feet
of the living
thank you
[Music]
sing it out with us
and I love you Lord for you have
delivered me
and I love you Lord
for you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my soul from
in the land of the living
amen
thank you guys I could hear you all
right kiddos you're dismissed here
classes if it's your first time then
four years old through first grade goes
right here to my left and second through
sixth to my right and any babies or
younger toddlers are welcome back in the
nursery
down that hallway
[Music]
thank you to our kids ministry workers
as usual for the ways that you serve us
we're so grateful
we are going to enter into the prayers
of the people now so um if you guys
would read this prayer aloud with me and
then we're going to take space for you
to offer up what you may be carrying
into this room whether it's a situation
or a person that's on your heart please
share that with us and we will hold that
up before God together and if you're
online feel free to leave that in the
comments and then we'll continue with
the rest of the prayer
Read With Me Jesus for the city of
Sachse Texas and for every city and
community and all who live in them we
pray to you
for The Good Earth you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it
we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you
for the vulnerable the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
thank you
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
amen
[Music]
you broke my chains
with your Holy Fire you'll cover me with
Grace
[Music]
it is for Freedom
that I am set free
[Music]
you roll my chains
you made my life
[Music]
it is
[Applause]
[Music]
please
yes Lord we are grateful for your grace
and for your love
[Music]
yes Lord we are grateful for your grace
and for your love
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I am set free
it is
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
please
[Music]
it is
is for Freedom
that I am
set free
[Music]
yes God would you continue to meet us
here would we sense your presence as we
let go
as we open up ourselves to you
[Music]
foreign
cause you made this sinner
holy and Hope
fully
[Music]
cause your glory is so beautiful
I hold on to my knees in
[Music]
the heartbeat of my life is to Worship
in your sight
your glory is so beautiful
oh
[Music]
and my life is yours
oh
holy
[Music]
cause your glorious so beautiful
in the heartbeat of my life is to
Worship in your life
your glory is so beautiful
Your Glory is so beautiful
[Music]
oh
and Glory Glory
Hallelujah
Jesus you are good
and Glory Glory
[Music]
Glory Glory
Hallelujah
Jesus you are good
and Glory
Glory
Hallelujah
Jesus you are good
and what can wash away
my sins
nothing but the blood of
Jesus
in what can make me whole again
nothing but the blood of
Jesus is
[Applause]
[Music]
nothing but the blood of Jesus just the
voices
[Music]
nothing but your blood
oh Jesus
[Music]
oh nothing but your blood
we thank you for your blood Jesus
[Music]
and Glory Glory Hallelujah
Hallelujah
Jesus you are good
Glory Glory
Hallelujah
Jesus
you are good
[Music]
you are so good to us
we celebrate that you're with us each
step of the way
we celebrate that you love us
in both the Good Seasons and the bad
that you came to rescue us
from ourselves
from our Darkness
from our fear
[Music]
from our anxiety
from our hatred and our prejudice
and our pride
[Music]
you came to call us forward
to show us the way of Jesus
the way of love
God we open ourselves up to that tonight
and tomorrow and this week God would it
do its good work in our hearts
in Jesus name
amen
you guys can turn and greet the people
around you say hello make them feel
welcome and then Brett will get us
started on our message
well Grace and peace
I am here
I am uh not feeling great you know
somebody seen the masco's word I uh I
I'm negative for kovitz that's good but
um I'm just just Dragon so
um I don't know if you'll maybe I'll
like
get into I don't know we'll see we'll
just see how it goes
um but I am uh I'm glad glad to be here
with you all and
um the ibuprofen is kicking in so I'm
feeling a little better
um so
um I want to welcome all of you and that
as always includes those showing us
online I love you all lots and
um yeah it's just really really good to
to be here with you all
um so we are in our Series right now um
on the book of James
and um just covering some of the major
themes insights from it so a lot of
these you know a lot of times I'll have
like one or two even two passages
sometimes because they're just you know
we're not really going through the book
but just the the major themes and
insights from it and
um so the the title of the message
tonight is the overlooked secret to
wisdom
the overlooked secret to wisdom and our
text tonight is from James chapter three
uh verses 13 through 18.
and James writes these words who is wise
and understanding among you
let them show it by their Good Life by
Deeds Done in the humility that comes
from wisdom you can hear how James keeps
coming back to these themes of living
you know how does this get lived
um he continues verse 14 but if you
Harbor bitter envy and selfish ambition
in your hearts do not boast about it or
deny the truth such wisdom does not come
down from heaven but is Earthly
unspiritual
demonic
for where you have envy and selfish
ambition there you find disorder and
every evil practice but the wisdom that
comes from Heaven is first of all pure
then peace loving considerate submissive
full of mercy and good fruit impartial
and sincere
whenever there's like a list like that I
always think of it's almost like poetry
where you're you're trying to say
something that can't quite be said or
captured you know so you just keep
throwing words like comma comma comma
you know you're just trying to give you
kind of the the spirit of the of the
thing you know
um Verse 18 peacemakers who sow in peace
reap a harvest of righteousness
so there is
um there's a story it's actually over in
First Kings
um famous story of a young
uh man Scholars sort of speculate it
might have been like in his very early
20s maybe even late teens
um but his name was Solomon and he uh in
the story he's in like a major
transition because his father uh King
David had passed away uh you can imagine
this is always like a uh
anxiety-inducing time for
um really a kingdom you know when
someone the king passes away and it's
sort of like oh hope this goes smoothly
you know
um and so there's Solomon at like 19 20
and he's now going to be the king of
Israel
and he's honestly kind of freaking out
internally
um so he goes to sleep one night
and the Lord appears to him in a dream
and says Solomon
ask of me whatever you want
and I'll give it to you
and Solomon's answer is
so surprising
for a 20 year old I know I would not
have answered this way when I was 20. I
mean really I think this is like one of
the highlights of scripture
um I mean it's almost it's just
beautiful how he puts it
um so he he says oh Lord
now I'm only a little child I don't know
how to carry out my duties
but God give me a wise and Discerning
heart to govern your people to
distinguish between right and wrong
for who is able to govern this great
people of yours
and the Lord responds to him
and to kind of paraphrase he basically
says like I love that answer I love I
forget love it and and he says in fact
he says because you have not asked and
then he starts to list the things
Solomon didn't ask for
that I probably would have
um I love the list too it's very the
last one in particular is very kingly
um so he says because you haven't asked
for long life
or wealth
or the death of your enemies that's the
kingly one the death of your enemies
um because you haven't asked for these
things
um
but instead you ask for discernment and
administering Justice I will do what you
have asked I will give you a wise and
Discerning heart
and I remember early like when I was
back like these kiddos age hearing this
story
um for the first time
and uh I honestly I was quite
unimpressed by Solomon's answer
I just thought you
much money you know I think just my
eight-year-old brain just couldn't
comprehend anything more than like on
cars or something
um but of course now you know at 39
going on 40 and uh now I can now I get
it
now I get it now I see why like oh
um because life is so challenging
and you know money don't get me wrong
can be helpful quite helpful especially
you don't have enough of it you know
it's like oh gosh
um
but
boy in the end what a gift
to
have wisdom to have discernment like
that that sense of being in the moment
and knowing what to say
or not to say
right in the moment it's needed
to know what to do
right when it's needed like that
what a gift
um I can remember being in my 20s and
like the the question at least in
Christian circles of people in their 20s
it was the like main thing people would
ask for
um like you do prayer requests and
whatever in small groups is like help me
like I need I need to know my purpose
I've noticed now that I'm like pushing
40 now that's not I don't really hear
that as much
um but maybe I don't know maybe it's
like a 20s thing
um of just like I need to know my
purpose like you know it's just this
major transition kind of like Solomon
just a major life transition season and
you need to know what to do you know and
um boy there is there's something so
just stunningly beautiful and helpful
about wisdom to know what to say to know
what to do
um yeah right when it's needed
and uh
of course you know the poets the
prophets like they've been telling us
this for thousands of years I mean the
whole you've read The Book of Proverbs
uh it's just like this over and over
again
um and you just like get wisdom pursue
wisdom more than mansions or fast cars
or million dollars or anything I mean
pursue wisdom seek wisdom get wisdom
wisdom like just
I'm hammering at home you know and yet
uh I don't know about you but I still
struggle
um struggle with wisdom struggle to even
honestly to desire I think I just get
distracted in life and uh
yeah I kind of got me thinking like it's
interesting that
everyone says we want wisdom
but then so few have it
you know I mean just think of I don't
know you're like friend or two or three
like that wise person that you go to for
like perspective
and they're not swept up in your drama
you know it's like you go to them and
they're that kind of steadying presence
um
that's a rare person you know it's a
rare person
but what a gift
what a gift to a church Community to a
small group to a family
my goodness like it's just
um absolutely absolutely incredible
so
like why is this why is it so rare and
verse 13 James writes who is wise and
understanding among you let them show it
by their Good Life by Deeds Done in the
humility that comes from wisdom that's
our key word for tonight this is really
what I want to reflect on like why is
wisdom like everyone says like oh yeah
of course I want wisdom like I love that
sell them a story like agreed let's
wisdom's great you know but then why do
so few have it uh I wonder if it's that
word
if it's humility sort of like everyone
wants wisdom I'll just be for myself I
won't put this on you
um I want wisdom I just don't want to be
humble you know if I get some wisdom
without the humility side
um this would be the thing I'd sign up
for
um but it seems like that's the you know
kind of the barrier
um
in fact if you kind of read the rest of
the passage with this word humility in
mind
you'll notice that it's like a contrast
the whole passage is sort of a contrast
to the humble person
uh verse 14 but if you Harbor bitter
envy and selfish ambition
in your hearts
all right can you see the kind of
contrast happening
do not boast about it or deny the truth
such wisdom so-called kind of the square
scare quotes such wisdom does not come
down from heaven but his Earthly
unspiritual demonic for where you have
envy and selfish ambition there it is
again there you find disorder in every
evil practice in other words there's a
sort of
um false wisdom parading around and it's
like when we say we want wisdom often it
seems like actually that's kind of what
we want
um like a little bit of
uh uh kind of cleverness
knowledge that kind of empowers us
to all the selfish ambition stuff he was
talking about to like get ahead I mean
when I think of like American culture
that is the obsession
uh like it just feels like 75 of people
to spend on personality but like that's
sort of the the cultural
Spirit you know the value is just a a
kind of that false wisdom that wants us
to get ahead I think of
all of the
um YouTube boy if I had a dollar for
every YouTube video I've seen devoted to
helping me get ahead
it's like I don't know what the
algorithm is feeding y'all but it's just
like you've seen me and he's like
um get ahead and this and that and or if
I had a dollar for every
um every video or like Tick Tock reel or
um or with Instagram real Tick Tock
video of uh like anything with this
language like the captions the headlines
that are like the language of dominance
and winning
um I jotted down a few that I've seen
last few weeks atheist owned by
Christian apologists conservative
humiliated by liberal
snowflake college student crushed by
conservative scholar you know I mean
apparently these are getting a lot of
views like we love this kind of stuff
we're just like yes
like you know I mean it's sort of back
to you know humiliating my enemies and
conquering and getting to the top of the
mountain so to speak you know not the
mountain of wisdom but the different
Mountain like this is sort of what we're
um what we're into it's it's what James
calls like a false
um a false kind of wisdom so here's just
sort of our big idea um
for tonight you cannot scale the
mountain of wisdom
without first descending into the valley
of humility
that's the idea that is sort of like you
want to start on that wise path you know
you can take like a few steps you can
get going but pretty soon you'll notice
that path is going down and you're like
oh no I want to go up there but it's
first you descend into the valley of
humility another way to maybe frame it
is um you want to take wisdom 201 you
got to take humility 101.
you know one of these proceeds the other
leads into so I started thinking like
why is this why does humility lead to
wisdom so I'm going to give you three
things tonight classic sermon three
points
um number one humility leads to wisdom
because it opens me to learning
makes a lot of sense right it's like to
become wise we need to take in we need
to learn you know but of course if
you're lacking humility you're like well
I don't need to learn anything I've I
pretty much know it
uh so of course it becomes a non-starter
like
can you learn
it was a reminder of Solomon's opening
words in First Kings 3 7. this is
exactly how he puts it he says
but I'm only a little child and I do not
know how to carry out my duties that's
what then he goes into his request for
wisdom and I thought boy isn't that like
the most unpopular words in all of
American culture I don't know
I don't I honestly I need to say that
more often
um it's just a habit almost to just try
to give an answer even when I maybe
don't even have a good one I noticed I
do this with my kids so like ask me some
questions I have no idea I start making
crap up I don't know I'm like I just I
guess I don't know I don't want to look
stupid or something you know um I I
don't know that's those are powerful
powerful words
many years ago there was a I love some
of these there's some great stories in
the Zen tradition so I'll share one with
you there's uh many years ago there's
this wise and master and people would
like
travel from uh great distances to like
come to him for his wisdom and
perspective you know and uh so one day
there was a renowned scholar
known
um known for his deep deep knowledge in
vast learning and he came and made the
strip to visit this in master and when
he got there in a rather kind of haughty
kind of way he said I have come today to
have you teach me about Zen opened my
mind to enlightenment
and the Zen master smiled and said um
well you know that sounds like something
we should discuss over a cup of tea
and so
they had someone bring some tea to have
this Kettle you know when he goes and he
begins to pour this scholar his tea any
pours any pours you all heard the story
it's so great
it fills up right to the brim but he
keeps on pouring it overflows the cup it
flows onto the table it starts spilling
off onto this renowned Scholars robes
finally he can't take it anymore and he
says enough enough stop it can't you
idiot like can't you see it's full
Master says
um he smiled at his guest and he said
like this cup
you are full of your own ideas and
opinions
how can I teach you anything unless you
first empty your cup
that's a word like church
empty your cup
there's something about
um
opening ourselves saying like I what it
what if maybe it's even we can frame it
as a question like what if I don't know
what if I don't know
instead of needing to kind of paper over
my insecurity by like rushing to the to
an answer you know what if I just said I
don't I don't know
and then what might that begin to open
up
um some of you a quick footnote on this
are in a process of deconstruction
with your faith and really questioning
some things and
tearing some things apart and asking all
the hard questions this I think can be
one beautiful part of that process we'll
get to something later that can be a
little bit of a challenge with it this
is something that I think could be
really good with deconstruction is it's
this process of kind of unlearning so
that I can learn
you know saying huh maybe I don't know
maybe I don't know
all right so second humility leads to
wisdom because it opens me to
self-awareness
Saint Isaac the Syrian he said the
person who has attained to knowledge of
their own weakness has reached the
summit of humility I really like that
quote because it got me thinking like
it's good I think Clarity on what
humility is about humility as I've said
before it's not humiliation it's not oh
I'm such a worm I'm nothing
you know no no just humiliating
self-talk that's not humility instead
humility is this um really powerful
awareness a self-awareness of
um I know who I am and I know what I'm
good at in my strengths
and what
I know what I'm not so good at and my
weaknesses and I'm aware at some level
of how those are manifesting showing up
and so I've got kind of an eye for like
oh
be careful you know
um this is a very very
powerful thing there was a study by the
Harvard Business Review they actually
was like a collection all these
researchers who had done separate
studies they came together kind of
pulled their results they did like 10
different studies 5 000 different
participants around
um self-awareness and what they found
was that
um going into the study about 85 to 90
percent of people considered themselves
what
self-aware
um but what they found was it was the
exact inverse
so actually 85 to 90 percent were not
only 10 to 15 which is a little bit
startling and of course I don't know
about you but when I read that I was
like well just thank God I'm in the 10
to 15 you know
um
which is sort of like right this is the
problem this is what we do you know
we're just like yeah can you believe
those people there's someone self-aware
it is like embarrassing
um and the the second thing they they
found was in terms of how to grow in
self-awareness I found this very
interesting
um they said a certain amount of
introspection can be helpful I'm
thinking here of like even classic
spiritual practices in the Christian
tradition
um you know journaling and prayer and
meditation and going on a silent Retreat
you know and facing your inner world and
that they found that is one way to grow
in some self-awareness to do some some
soul searching so to speak you know
but they found that actually the most
powerful way to change
and the one that no one wants to do
is
um opening yourself up to the feedback
of other people
that that like if you want to grow in
self-awareness
like that's the way
um to to open yourself the way I would
kind of summarize their the research is
to say to grow and wisdom I need
consistent loving and honest feedback
from people I trust about the way I'm
showing up in the world
I think this is a danger even of um kind
of American culture where we just get in
our little little
um
households you know whether that's uh
you as a you know a single person
household of one or a family or four or
whatever like we just kind of get
trapped in our household
and
we fall into ways of relating and we
often lack a broader Community who is
willing to speak the truth in love
to us
I think this is one of the great gifts
even though it's a little bit painful
and difficult one of the great gifts
that perhaps the table what we could
offer one another
is um
hey
here's how you're coming across now of
course here's the thing
um I would encourage you if you're
wondering like well how do I do this you
know uh I would encourage you not to go
around pointing out everyone else's
stuff you know
um instead I would suggest go go to a
few people you trust and give them
permission
to give you this feedback I did this um
a while back with my kids
and all of them separately their
feedback to me was you get too angry
that's what they said I was like no I
doubt
um no I didn't do it but uh it is I mean
it's a little bit honestly it's a little
bit startling
you know we we just we do we don't quite
know
how we're coming across so yeah can you
see where this might lead to some wisdom
um growing in in self-awareness
um third and finally humility leads to
wisdom because it opens me to the
Christian tradition
um I really wrestled with how to say
this let me um let me give you kind of a
a definition like what uh what I mean
the Christian tradition I remember I
spoke like years ago I was actually at a
previous Church community I was
preaching and I kept using this phrase
the Christian tradition the crit now in
the Christian tradition
and someone came up to me um afterwards
and they're like what are you talking
about
the Christian tradition you know I mean
it was one of those little turns of
phrase that I realized I'd slipped into
and just started to think in terms of
but
um apparently no one knew what I was
talking about so here's um let me give
you a little definition
um Christian tradition in ongoing
conversation and practice
across time that's key so it's not just
about Community or like the people right
now right here
um it's across time
and about Christ God the truth the good
how to live wisely and well
and um
something I think is really lacking in
kind of the modern world is this idea of
participating in a tradition
[Music]
um
what I mean is even if we say like well
I don't want the Christian tradition I
just want Jesus
and it's like yeah but here's the thing
to learn what does that mean I want to
follow Jesus I'm going to live like
Jesus I'm gonna you know do that
um or even place it in a more secular
context someone who's like well I don't
know about Jesus but I just you know I
want to live wisely and well I want to
live a good life I'm going to figure out
how to do that
um and often I think what we've kind of
done is sort of cut ourselves off
um in the modern world from tradition I
was on a ski trip riding home with a few
friends and they were
three friends all had kind of
deconstructed and deconstruct themselves
out of Christian faith
and um
somewhat shockingly at least to them in
this conversation I was imploring them I
was like almost begging them
like I've had this conversation over and
over and over with people like so
encouraging like hey look I've I've
freaking love the Christian tradition I
love cheese I think it's great but if
that for all the reasons you know it
can't work for you
okay please
please
find a tradition that's what I was
telling them like find something like
it's not anything because there can be
really bad traditions you know and even
within any tradition there can be
problems you know I'm not trying to say
like it's the Christian tradition so
pristine you know
um I was like
begging them to do this and you could
tell they were completely baffled by me
bimbo like just like
what
what do you what where like where are
you coming from and I just as I've kind
of thought about it and I tried to
articulate it then but I've continued to
think about it it just it feels like
this generation is so ruthless
like we're all just making our life up
as we go
without any handles it's like we need
not just a community but we need a
tradition we need the wisdom of previous
generations this is one way to think of
what a religion is it's it's a carrier
of wisdom
right like it's a sort of assuming that
people from the past weren't just idiots
but like they learned something about
living and then it's this whole like
conversation and practice that um we
like get engrafted into how to live well
and
um I just think we need this like for
example like if you wanted to take up um
use kind of a silly example like surfing
you're like I want to learn to surf I'm
like awesome so who are you gonna go
learn from no one
nope and we're like okay are you gonna
like read a book on it nope no books no
no podcasts no perspective no mentors no
community of surfers nope I'm just going
it alone I'm just gonna start from
scratch and just teach myself and just
do it that way like can you see where
they would just be like why
what no like if you want to learn
surfing you engage in the tradition you
know what I mean of Surfing
um I think in a similar way there's
something
so helpful and Powerful about
engaging a tradition like this
and letting it shape us form us guide us
and wrestling with it right because it's
not just about like accepting Hook Line
and sync or whatever the mother Church
says or Pastor Brad or Bishop so-and-so
you know they're the tradition you know
um no it's about it's like a wrestling a
wrestling with it
um but knowing like you do that and like
five ten years down the road
you'll be grateful you did it'd be
grateful you did so um
so that's it humility leads to wisdom
because it opens me to learning to
self-awareness and to the Christian
tradition in the name of the Father the
Son of the holy spirit amen
so um as we come to the table of the
Lord
tonight so we take in the body of Christ
in the bread the blood of Christ in the
wine we do so as a people opening
ourselves up to God and and as a people
engaging a very very old tradition
um one that shapes us informs Us in the
way of the crucified uh in the
resurrected one
so I hope that as you engage this
there'll be you know something in your
own heart and mind that's like opening
opening up to God opening up to
um what he wants to teach you
so the way we'll do this we'll start
from the front work our way back we
practice what's called an open table so
you can anyone is welcome to participate
and you can just go ahead and partake
whenever you'd like and red is wine
why does grape juice
so this is the table
not at the church but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith in you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow and you who
have failed
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
table
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we're going to close out with an old
hymn called be thou my vision and I have
always loved the words of this hymn and
I think one of the things I appreciate
about it is um
just the spirit of humility that it was
written in
because opening ourselves up to the
vision of Christ to seeing things
through the eyes of Christ like Brett
was saying requires us letting go of
some of our own perspectives some of our
own knowings or
um
you know our own confidence is and
relying on his and letting him speak to
us letting him show us his ways see
through his eyes
so if you guys would stand with us we're
going to sing this hymn together
Maggie's gonna lead us in it so whenever
you're ready
[Music]
peace out my vision
oh lord of my heart
foreign
[Music]
thank you
be thou my wisdom and thou my true words
I
ever with the end of
thou my great father
in Thy Thy true son
thou win me dwelling and I with the
world
foreign
[Music]
thy Victory one
may I reach
Heaven's Joys bright Heavens Sun
[Music]
heart of my heart
whatever before
still be my vision
oh ruler of all
oh ruler of
thanks so much for being with us tonight
I hope that the service the worship the
people blessed you right where you are
don't forget about hat Creek tonight
we'll meet there right after the service
we would love to have you there and be a
part of that if you're visiting with us
tonight please before you leave fill out
a visitor card those are on the little
table right as you go out the the door
back here
also we have a QR code
that is attached to a link tree those QR
codes you can scan it up on the screen
and we also have some cards out there on
the tables that also have the QR code
you can sign up for our e-letter you can
sign up to attend a Meetup which are
small groups here it just gives you a
good at a glance look at ways to connect
here at the table so we'd love to do for
you to do that on your way out if you
need prayer a hug someone to talk to
before you leave please come find me I
would love to be there for you in that
way
um and also you know as Brett was
talking about uh just living into the
Christian tradition living
generationally it made me think of how
the table is doing that how are we
contributing to the Christian tradition
how are we contributing to the Next
Generation what are we passing along I
hope that we're doing that through our
values our inclusivity ways of being the
church that maybe are being done in in
hopefully healthier ways
and one way that that gets expressed and
one way we can continue to keep things
going here at the table is Honestly by
giving financially one of my favorite
quotes is
um
you the way that you want to see the
world expressed comes out through your
giving every time you spend money it's a
vote for the kind of world that you want
to see and I know for me the reason I
give one of the reasons I give to the
table is because I want our world to be
more thoughtful in inclusive loving more
christ-like so if this community and the
mission and what we're doing here speaks
to you please consider giving
financially you can do that by scanning
the code or the box that's out on the
little tiny table out in the hallway and
we would love for you to Worship in that
way as well along with all the ways we
worship here
and then lastly I would like to leave
you with a benediction as you go into
your week and I want to let you know
that this benediction was written
specifically for this community it was
written for you so I hope you receive it
in that way and also if if it resonates
with you we have the benediction written
out and you can just grab one of these
cards on your way out and have it as a
reminder throughout your week
you can receive them in addiction with
hands open or just with your heart open
are a child of God
you are a child of God
this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted Just
As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts to
everyone you come in contact this week
have a good night be blessed and we hope
to see you at hat Creek good night
[Music]
[Applause]
now my grace
[Music]
[Applause]